because i haven't
fully told them the whole story um and
so i think it's unfair for them
i have to be in the right place i've
gone to therapy to talk about it but you
know it's topics involving suicide
addiction
[Music]
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen and my new series fed up
every episode i'm gonna be sitting down
with a fellow influencer or content
creator to ask some of the tough
questions and have real uncensored
unscripted discussions without the shame
and judgment because we're all a little
fed up right
today i'll be talking to one of
youtube's most popular fitness and
lifestyle creators kelty o'connor but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
scentbird so considering that i've spent
the last i don't know four years with
fresh babies and living in a pandemic
i can count on one hand the number of
date nights that i've had since becoming
a mom but as i discussed in my glow up
video
now that my kids are getting a little
bit older and also things are starting
to open back up again
i'm trying to make more of an effort
sometimes it's the little things like
blow drying my hair or putting on makeup
that just makes me feel more energized
as silly as that sounds
but i recently found out about scentbird
which is a fragrant subscription service
that gives you the opportunity to shop
from over 600 brands to try every month
for just 16
their vials are eight times bigger than
a typical perfume sample and you get a
30 day supply of everything so you can
give it a go before you commit to a full
bottle
and if you want you can upgrade to
receive two or three products per month
if you want to switch things up
but you basically fill out their quiz to
discover scents that you'll like or you
can choose from their top designer
brands list
so based on my quiz results i got
badgley mishka which smells like pear
magnolia and jasmine so good another one
i got was cicely paris which smells like
peonies which are my all-time favorite
flower
and then i've also got good habits align
which has the scent of black currants
and white amber so i am definitely
looking forward to putting these to good
use tonight on our date night out so if
you want to give scentbird a try you can
use my code abby sharp to get 30 off of
your first month using the link in my
bio so that's just 11 for your first
month and my canadian followers will be
so happy to note that they also now ship
up here as well so yay for smelling
delicious
now before we dive in i want to remind
you to check out my disclaimer including
a trigger warning to those with past or
previous experiences with disordered
eating i also want to remind everyone to
of course subscribe to this channel and
ring that bell so that you never miss
out on an episode
well thank you so much kelty for joining
me thank you for having me i'm so
excited like i'm glad we can actually
have like a full conversation we will
kind of talk briefly so i'm excited
for sure
um for those who haven't watched your
content yet can you tell us a little bit
like how would you describe your videos
and style
so
my videos i guess like the core of like
my purpose in making it would be the
best ways like i'm just uh one to get
the most out of life and just kind of
challenge my body and prove myself that
i'm capable of more than i think and
just get the most out of my life so go
on adventures travel the world and so
hopefully i make really
entertaining uh content around that and
maybe inspires people to achieve a goal
they've always wanted to but yeah at the
end of the day it's just doing those
things i've always wanted to do and
making content around it i love that
so you went from being a college
basketball player to transitioning to a
full-time youtuber and i watched your
100-day body transformation journey
video and in it you mentioned that you
suffered from some severe identity
crisis after ending your sports career
and you also hinted that you overcame
some of like really dark thoughts there
um do you want to talk about that or
where you are right now with sharing the
story
yeah for sure this is
we're going to hit deep right away with
this so you know i just want to warn
anyone some of even the verbiage i'm
even just becoming comfortable saying
and
it's
to sum it up it'd be considered post
career syndrome and it's something i
stopped playing basketball due to injury
so it was something like i didn't even
mentally prepare for because usually you
know the end of your career with
basketball in college you're like oh
four years but when my ended
unexpectedly um yeah post career
syndrome just means i spent my whole
life being like describe yourself i'd be
like a tall
blonde athlete then like i do school too
and suddenly everything flipped i was
planning to go to med school i was you
know planning to finish out my degree as
a varsity athlete and then it was all
stripped away from me and i just
distinctly remember one day being in the
bar and a guy came up to me i just had
surgery and he's like what'd you do and
i just stared at this guy blankly and i
was like oh my god i
and like the poor guy he was probably
like what is this what's this going on
this girl's head but
and it was a very very dark time and
it's you know it's verbage that can get
you demonetized so i'm even trying to be
careful with saying it and that's why
i've never done my fitness journey video
um yet because
even though i want to have it and i've
kind of hinted at some of the things
that uh sorry if i get teary-eyed in
this um it's more like respect to my
family and my boyfriend and my best
friends because i haven't
fully told them the whole story um and
so i think it's unfair for them
i have to be in the right place i've
gone to therapy to talk about it but you
know it's topics involving suicide
addiction um other words i can't even
say with it you're getting demonetized
and so
it was just um
i lost everything i knew who i was and
i'm a very energetic high
uh you know
just a very energetic individual
suddenly and very goal orientated i know
goals all this energy and i went down a
very slippery slope for many of years
and i think it's something that's just
not talked about a lot and that's why i
do want to make the video um because
i've seen it i've seen friends i've seen
family members who are all former
athletes and i don't want to just
generalize athletes i think it can be
high academic people that get out of the
college or just people that musicians
have a definition and they lose that for
whatever reason
and i i do plan on making that video and
i think i've kind of hinted at some
parts of it and it's in the works but i
want to do it respectfully for like
who i
the the people i'm closest to but then
also it is a really important message
and just like mental health the more we
start talking about the more i wish i
was aware of it because i said when that
person asked me i didn't know it was an
identity crisis it took me five or six
years to realize oh you went down that
really dark path because you had no
purpose no identity and
you just latched on to anything you
could possibly get well thank you for
sharing that that's um
that's so brave of you and i and i also
hope that you can make that video at
some point because i agree you know a
lot of these topics are not talked about
enough and there's so such a need to
reduce that stigma by you know sharing
this with our community and we have such
a big platform
so yeah i hope that you find a time and
place where that's something that you're
comfortable with i know i
certainly suffered from a similar
situation myself
ending my kind of academic career i was
on path to do a phd um i had a full
scholarship i was you know top of the
class um i had a pretty much perfect gpa
everyone was kind of rooting for me to
to win all these awards and and and and
do all these amazing academic accolades
and and i dropped out of graduate school
and i had a complete identity crisis
because i felt like that was all that i
was i was just the smart one i was the
one who you know put my hand up and knew
the answer to every question and i
didn't even know who i was after that
and uh and it felt like i was literally
jumping into the abyss when i dropped
out um but i'm obviously so glad that i
did look where i am now and that was
such an important step for me to take
and and clearly you as well like you've
you've made such an amazing exciting
career for yourself so i'm really glad
that that it's worked out for you yeah
and i think it just resonates and just
us even opening up about this and i hope
anyone listening when i think you've
mentioned this and i've even seen you
have tick talks about it and like i
mentioned it is just knowing like when
you get to that dark place and lose your
identity you still have all those
foundations that just means you're
really smart you can you know there's so
many more things you can learn and then
there's such greater things to look
forward to and that would be even just
my little self is that's the journey i'm
on that's why i'm like milk life for all
of its work absolutely and i mean so
you've made that shift now to being you
know an athlete sharing your life so
publicly on youtube what was your
rationale for wanting to go into the
youtube space
this is a complicated one a little bit
um it's not very smooth uh light switch
but for me you know we hit it back
before i thought i want to do med school
uh looking back the only reason i want
to do med school is because i love the
show grey's anatomy and i had good
grades and so it was like rational like
okay let's go be a doctor um spent a
little time in the hospital and was like
oh uh
respect to all doctors and all that i
was like oh you are not meant to be a
doctor and then suddenly as i got older
i realized i was like no no you like the
idea of being on grey's anatomy not
being a doctor and then um that was a
realization of i think basketball was a
great even though you're not a performer
you are an entertainer you're there
you're performing in front of crowds and
that was and i just grew up watching
youtube jenna marbles uh casey and i sat
like his nike commercial it like
inspired me in ways i could not even
begin
to uh describe and so i think i was just
trying to figure it out
i'm just trying lots of things and at
the time youtube i kind of had a bit of
an instagram following and so i just
played around with youtube and i tried a
hundred different things and it was just
genuinely i love
making entertaining content um for
people and that's just what i think i've
always done like when i was growing up
in high school i always asked not to do
essays if i could do movie presentations
um and i loved computer sciences and
back then that was there was absolutely
no monetization on youtube so i didn't
even think and then i just kind of
started dabbling into it and i was like
wow i
really like it so even though i fall
into like the fitness niche because i
just have that sports background and
like my mom was a personal trainer um
it was never really versus like i think
you come and that's why i not try not to
step over people like your feet that you
come with a nutrition background so
you're spewing education and that's what
i was like even though i'm in the
fitness community and i might be going
off on a tangent i was like it at the
end of the day is i just want to make
you know 10 minute video that someone
just like brightens their day and maybe
inspires them to like do something yeah
your content totally brightens my day i
love i love the editing i think it's
funny obviously i think you're funny and
witty and i think it's educational and
entertaining entertaining so i love
watching your channel and it's really
funny that you mentioned the thing about
grey's anatomy being like you know you
want to like be
like pretend kind of like on tv as you
were a doctor because i kind of came
into this industry in a similar way i
have a background in acting and
performance as a child um
and i did a lot of theater and a lot of
you know tv as a kid and
so i'm a dietician that's like that's my
knowledge base and that's kind of um my
profession but ultimately like i could
never work
in a kind of clinical setting as a
dietitian i i did it i i was unhappy i
knew that it was not for me i knew that
was not for me even before i even went
into becoming a dietitian i knew that i
needed an unconventional path because i
just couldn't sit in front of someone
and you know analyze their diet and and
go through that now again like you said
respect to all my clinical rds out there
it is hard work um
but ultimately you have to find your
kind of niche and exactly what fires
your your soul so i'm i'm glad that you
found something that works for you i
didn't want to interrupt i was like that
also makes sense why you're so good on
camera is like having that background
because obviously you have all the
science behind it but i was like but
then where do you also have this
christmas i was like oh it's like the
perfect just like crossroads of like
exactly where you have to be
exactly and i'm so obviously i'm so
grateful that i've had that opportunity
to make that that place for myself so
that's been a real blessing in my life
but it doesn't come without challenges
and i mean i find that industry that
this industry is really tough on my
mental health and i find like burnout is
really real and trolls are vicious
do you ever worry that this job is too
much for your mental health and i'm
wondering how you cope with some of the
non-stop you know public scrutiny and
critique
i think i might have not to be like oh
i'm so different but i might have like a
bit of a different perspective of i feel
really blessed that i started to get
some traction in my later 20s after i
overcame a lot of my mental health
issues like i look i know you
interviewed linda sun and like i feel
not like feel for her and like oh she's
a strong independent woman but i was
like she's growing up being vulnerable
in the public eye at least like even
though i'm always vulnerable i was like
if 20 year old kelter is on the internet
i'm like 10 emoji vibes like i'm getting
canceled like right and i had to
overcome a lot of things and i think
that kind of just taught me even just
being aware of like just different
mental health diagnosis and what
reacts well now that doesn't mean mental
health is just like physical health it's
not like you know i come from having
like a lot of issues like ocd and adhd
and a lot of others we could dive into
but i think just knowing that and having
the framework and it's going to be ebbs
and flows and
realizing it and i think that was really
thankful in that sense but in modern day
i still burn out and that's just a
reality and i think it's now not when i
had my first big burnout i felt like a
complete failure and i was like oh my
gosh like how you're you can't do it and
then suddenly i just realized that even
yesterday i had a conversation with my
boyfriend and he was like are you doing
okay you're off i'm like i'm like a week
away from burnout i need to change some
things up and it's just more of like
realizing that's especially when you're
constantly putting yourself on it's kind
of this hamster reel you every time i
just get a bit better at recognizing the
symptoms of it and
how to cope with it so i think it's
it's a learning process just like
fitness and food like you don't you're
not magically gifted with perfect mental
health maybe there is some people i'm
sure but even people with perfect mental
health you know covet did a lot of crazy
things for us and so i feel lucky in
that sense and i have a lot of
boundaries uh as simple as like i have
two phones uh because i have my phone
with social media and then on my phone
with my best friends and so after a
certain time the other one gets in the
drawer and you just can't get a hold of
me and i think you know i feel very
blessed that i can afford to but i think
it's just like that's even though it's
quite a cost it's like that's my mental
health right there like that's changed
it and so i think really having
boundaries and then in terms of the
trolls uh i feel very lucky that i just
have tried to create a community that's
very positive and i feel i have an
unbelievably positive community and of
course it's the internet i could say one
thing wrong people tear me apart
but for the most part i love criticism i
come from a sports background i almost
i'm gonna knock on every word because i
could eat this almost sometimes wish i
had a little bit more um because it's so
positive i'm like okay tell me like tell
me my mic isn't loud enough or that you
didn't like this thing i'm trying to
create the most entertaining content for
my audience so sometimes they're so nice
i'm like hey what do you want like what
can i change up to make it more
entertaining and then the trolls who
just pick apart those
i've just kind of gotten to that point
that i'm like if you are spending the
time to just pick apart someone i
know you're hurting there's something i
don't know what the dynamics is but i
genuinely feel bad for any trolls and
so i also don't dip into the drama and i
stay away and i could be a lot more
clickbaity into drama and going after
things but it's not worth my mental
health to go after that i'd rather have
a smaller subscriber base it's super
positive we are all supporting each
other then have 10 million subscribers
because i had to dive into drama and
sacrifice my own mental health so that's
kind of how i've handled it these are
fantastic tips taking note
the two phone thing everyone was like
watching they they must have seen my
eyes just like whoa why did i never
think of that that's [ __ ] genius um
i'm doing that like that's a fantastic
investment
think of how much money i could spend uh
save on therapy by just buying out a
phone like
that that transaction that transaction
works out in my opinion so
thank you okay so in your july video on
my hundred day body transformation
journey um you also shared this comment
from a viewer that basically called your
challenges like clickbaitish and
pointless and you said that this was
hard for you because you know your inner
struggles were now obvious to the
outside world
so i'm first of all curious what inner
struggles do you think that your viewers
were picking up on exactly so for me and
i don't want to sound like i feel very
privileged during covet that i'm still
able to work and that youtube if
anything picked up so i just want to
start off and be like i realized that
but where the mental health struggle was
is also not being open like i felt so
lucky that sometimes i didn't dig deep
and
if you go back to like february 2020
it's quite comical now but i was
completely rebranding my channel because
i was never really doing i was more just
chasing like hey these are what people
want that and i finally was like this is
the content i want to make and i travel
a lot it was my idea was you know travel
around the world trying different
fitness and foods from around the world
and i had like this just all these
different series
and then suddenly cove had happened and
i was like every single series that i
planned is not possible anymore and i
was like oh gosh but you know it was
tunnel vision i was like the world
didn't so i was like at home workouts
you know
after i did every at-home workout i was
like hey try celebrity thing just you
know i almost was just like just
making content to make it and i felt
very lucky and i'm not
hating myself for making those videos
like none were you know toxic or
anything but i was just kind of i was
like i could pump out these like nothing
but it wasn't like why i started youtube
there's no real oh my god i'm like i'd
publish that video and never watch it
again versus like when i do a good video
i want to share it to everyone i know
it's like it's um
and i just kind of and so i knew the
content that gets you all my titles and
i'd be like ugh this isn't what i want
to be doing and like which sounds kind
of awful like it was nothing too bad it
was just not what like i said let my
soul on fire was just like an average so
it just felt very nine to five job
and so i was just appealing to what
people i thought want not even just like
you know but truly understanding my
audience and then i think that really
hit because it was just very like basic
challenges i wasn't able to do
you know i had that big gymnastics video
and i was like i cancelled that
gymnastics video every three weeks for
like months on end and be like
discipline this cancel this so it was
just like and then i had no time so it
was like makeup what can i do in a week
and so yeah they were just week long
challenges you're not going to see
results and i tried to
show that and that was kind of just the
theme i had like only a week can only
change so much and i always tried to get
a message with it but it was hard seeing
like oh no people also think the same
and then i was like my channel's dying
and my purpose and and that's why like
it was really nice to finally travel and
go to sweden and just like step away and
be away from the distractions and then
just really dig down deep and like what
why did you start youtube what content
do you want to make and like what makes
you uniquely you and i think that's why
that 100 day journey was even though it
was my body transformation it was so
much more um it was just more of like
finding myself as an athlete and that
and so i think that's where it was it
was just a realization of like
and i'm not trying to feel bad so it's
just reality i couldn't make the content
i wanted and i did the best that i could
and i think a lot of us are probably
feeling that like we had to put a lot of
dreams and hopes on the back burner and
like to not feel guilty it was not us it
was just we did the best we could in the
time we had because you can't really
train as a gymnast in your like 400
square foot apartment
100 i'm sure everyone listening has
thoughts about that like no matter what
their profession is or what their their
life situation is like none of us have
been able to do everything we wanted to
do in the covid life and we've all had
to just kind of like make do with the
best we have like even just trying to
balance parenthood and work there are so
many days that i feel like i'm feeling
at everything i'm feeling at being a mom
and i'm feeling at my job and um you
know just cutting myself that slack to
be like you know what this is just gonna
be good enough and i've just had to
really kind of come to terms with that
and it has also been a process and
humbling process at that but i think
that a lot of people are feeling that so
um yeah i think thank you for sharing
that um and i'm also curious like i love
that you are kind of finding the content
that speaks to you and that you get
excited about as a content creator
because i feel like as creators so often
we get stuck in the
the game of just like creating content
that
is like clickbaity and like super
entertaining like based on what gets a
lot of views um and i'm just curious
like now like how are you balancing um
creating content that of course like
performs well but also like speaks to
you and your soul so the one that i've
done and i think this is the best way
and i'm not gonna
um hit it perfectly but i started my
fitness uh bucket list and it was
honestly just like a whim of a thought
and like people really resonate with it
especially um and so i just started
talking to my audience like what would
you guys like to see and not being like
oh they like this one the most i have to
do it it was just more i'm like honestly
i have always wanted to do that let's
add it to the list and i'm taking a bit
more of that approach not being like
this is most popular this is the best i
have to do that one occasion i won't lie
it just like sounds like a real big
challenge and maybe it's not the most
i'm like let's just see this video so
there or i i have such love for making
entertaining videos so i'm like okay if
i can make this super entertaining i i
thrive in that so
i'm not gonna perfectly follow it but i
think just that's the best
thing is just not doing it though just
solely because i know it'll perform well
like for example keto you know i i'm not
a keto person i
in the past would do it just simply
because i knew it would get views and
now i'm like no i know my body doesn't
respond well to that but versus you know
what was
a lot of people had um like rock
climbing as one that i was like yeah i
have always just never even crossed my
mind so i write it down and i think
that's going to be kind of
more of my approach is sacrificing some
of the things that i know are just seo
optimized and popular just and then not
being so scared of those things that
aren't seo optimized like i had a couple
that you know there's no reason it will
go big or anything but like this just
speaks to my soul so much and i i
hopefully that resonates with people and
then at the end of the day i think
that's the best you can do as content
creators like truly speak from your soul
and like your individual and that's what
makes you individual so i think that's
i won't do it perfectly but i think the
bucket list ironically yeah just was a
whim and i was like oh this was
everything i wanted to do even though it
sounds so simple
so let's talk about your challenges
again for a second so
as someone who creates a lot of content
around training and eating like
different celebrities and public figures
do you find it challenging on your body
and your mental health to just keep
making all these drastic changes to your
lifestyle in order to make these videos
see i get that
question quite often and i think a year
or like when i first started blowing up
like after tom brady video definitely
and that's why like i had burned out it
was just like i went from doing like
vegan for 30 days to keto for 30 days
and all this and like and i've never i
feel very blessed like i i was
definitely influenced by diet culture
just being someone born in the 90s and
but i never like diet wasn't a word in
our house like my mom never put us on on
that we were no foods redeemed not like
i feel very lucky and then suddenly i i
realized i was like in this cycle of
like i've never been on diets i'm never
promoted diet culture but i'm doing all
these diets because they're click baby
and my body's not and it was just like i
would lose weight and then be bloated
and it was just like this weird cycle
and now i think i can do it a lot more
subjectively and you know
i
always take an intuitive approach to it
i think that's what i even the only
reason i ever still do those videos is i
just kind of want to siphon in from all
the people being like oh i'm doing this
and being following it exactly this way
and this is how they do it and it's
right or wrong and i just try you know
the best example of the scarlett
johansson video i just did i did it
because i always wanted to train like a
marvel character i've always loved
marvel and her diet i saw it and i was
like i can't do that like i can't
perform like a marvel character and
train like that and eat that little
carbs now of course yeah if you're
paying me 50 million dollars maybe i
would i'd do anything for that but at
the same time i was like i'm not
promoting that so i talked about it and
explained you know what i will eat whole
foods this month but um i went out
drinking with my friends we had pasta
i'm not gonna stop that and so i just
without
commenting on it as like i would as a
registered dietitian because i also know
that's not my scope of practice i more
just say this is what works for my body
this is why i'm doing it or not or you
know
it's whenever i try a diet i
never reduce my portions or increase
them i've tried to do a lot more of that
i'm like this is just how much i need to
listen to my body and for the most part
the ones i do
everyone kind of eats the same if i eat
a little different every day like i've
never been someone that's like eats
exactly every day i being an athlete i
was always on the road like my body is
very adaptable to be like this is what
you eat like make do with it and so if
anything that's just kind of how i
naturally eat and so
that's why i did it but now just
definitely putting the hard boundaries
of like i'm not just gonna do months of
you know sacrificing myself for it and
that's what i used to do i was like i'm
stacking for myself to promote like
because i'd almost do it to show this
doesn't work and then i was like you
know what that's i'm breaking out and
it's just not worth it and i'm not
promoting because then you look at all
my titles and it looks like i'm
promoting diet culture when you get
click in the video and it's complete
opposite so i definitely that was
another reason for the burnout and just
being like i'm not making the contents i
want to make i was like
i i realized that every video is a dive
video and i am an anti-diet culture and
it's more about the training for me but
then i do know people like the food and
i love food so it's trying to find that
like i love food i love talking about
food i love exploring and trying
different things but at the same time
not
just
promoting
a yo-yo cycle that i've never been a
part of and suddenly i was doing that
just because
seo optimized keto
yeah and i think you do a really great
job at that and obviously not a lot of
channels do so i always appreciate that
and i'm like i'm curious but the
challenge is like when you started the
challenges was there ever
an intention there to
kind of promote a sense of like food
freedom or
um were you kind of more in it for the
entertainment value and the seo at the
beginning like i know you've mentioned
that your your kind of goals and your
mandates have changed um but what was
where were you at when you started that
so when i started it was definitely a
fluke and this is why it's like everyone
wants a viral video until they have a
viral video and i learned this the hard
way so my videos before i had my first
spiral one were very like i was just
trying different like i would do orange
story fitness for her like just her
first time i tried crossfit i do and
that was how i started to get traction i
used to actually do i started out
vlogging and they did fashion hauls and
then that was where i was like okay this
is fun i'm traveling around canada
showing different workouts and that's
what i thought was my thing and then
just one day on buzzfeed i saw the tom
brady video and someone did it for 24
hours and they had all these views like
24 hours that's nothing i was like i'll
do and i've been just being transparent
partying for like three months i was new
to toronto i was going out i wasn't
eating healthy and i was like you know
what if there was ever a time to just
like because all that like i wasn't in a
diet like i wasn't trying to do that i
was like just a lot of nutrient-dense
foods for a bit let's do it and the
video
ended up blowing up and so suddenly i
was like oh this is what people want so
buzzfeed's most popular diet videos
start just doing that and that's
definitely where
i started doing it which came finding
i've never really my weights kind of
fluctuated naturally like it always does
within 5-10 pounds but i've never had a
big weight loss or weight gain journey
um just a little bit uh here and there
and so that was a big realization when i
told you pre-covered where i was like
hey kelsey what are you doing like
you're just doing these just because and
i always try to have an intuitive
message because if you on i wouldn't
even label myself like an intuitive
eater cause i just don't label how i eat
i just listen to my body and i enjoy
food and i love nutrient dense food and
i love pasta and beer and
you know i just try to enjoy life to its
fullest and yeah so i might be getting a
long way around to get to that answer
but i think that i definitely felt that
as well is that it just kind of murked
that i never want to promote a diet if
someone really responds well to keto or
vegan i will never demonize them like
it's all about what works even perfectly
for you um
and yeah i think that was just a
realization of it just happened i just
got even got trapped in it i was like
this would be one and more warmer and
then one day i had to step back it was
like
why the hell are you doing this and so
that's definitely there's the
everyone wants the viral video until
it's not the perfectly you video and
i've had that recently even that's been
some videos that i truly feel are my
soul do well and i'm like ah
that's the kind of viral video you want
yeah i feel you on that because i mean
the exact same thing happened to me i my
freely review video went viral um and
that's what kind of kicked off all the
diet review videos that everyone's
obsessed with and i've really over the
years of course refined my delivery um
just as i found myself personally and
professionally and also have had to like
find my why like ask myself
what is my what is my purpose in these
videos other than just being sassy and
and um
and snarky sometimes which we love which
we love never change that
right we love we love a good sass factor
um but i'm i'm always trying to
find ways to communicate nutrition
information in an entertaining way and
ultimately to take down diet culture
because i think on youtube specifically
but really like all social media tick
tock is the worst um there's just so
much misinformation and so much
problematic um kind of diet advice
that a lot of young folks
specifically women
young women are very vulnerable to
following and i have a lot of very young
followers who
are trapped in these this cycle of diet
culture and so um i think for me like my
why is like i need to let these people
know that this is not the diet that they
should be following and here's why and
ultimately to teach people a little bit
about how to find their own intuition
when it comes to food nutrition and i
think that your videos do a really
really awesome job at that too even if
you're not explicitly coming out and
being like here's how to eat intuitively
you just are demonstrating it every
single day so
i love that that's always the comments i
i like that like i've tried to never
make it a big deal that i'm eating pizza
i'm like just eat the pizza and i think
that shows like i think sometimes people
it puts so much hype on it and i'm like
no just savor like the crust and the
crunchiness and the butter and the oil
and i just try to savor it like really
make it sound cause that's why i love
food i was like there's soul in
something that's handmade and like
that's where like food is such art to me
and i've always tried to just present it
and i think that's where i'm never like
you have to eat intuitively but i'm like
but if you're eating like here come to
the good side come over here like
there's a lot of fun stuff and i've
always tried to just like show like
enjoy in life um and like you said that
was definitely my mission like i feel i
had like a second it's not second
awakening but i had a second chance at
life and i'm like i'm gonna milk this
for everything it's worth and i hope
unfortunately i think especially coming
from sports i saw it a lot is a lot of
girls are trapped in diet culture and i
see it so much on tik tok and youtube
and it's just i just want to demonstrate
you can be really healthy you can be
athletic you can you know and enjoy life
like that that's always kind of just
like my mission so even though we
presented in different ways i think
that's definitely like we have the same
end goal in our content like you come
from like truly showing the steps and
i'm just like that's kind of where i
even like my channels it shows like oh
kelty eats intuitively she does this and
like but if someone needs like hard
facts they could go to a channel like
yours and you would be able to present
like you know here's how you like
literally do it and i think that's like
a beautiful thing of like this new
community that's coming on in youtube
and really presenting healthy you know
things and not just click bait detox
teas
yeah 100
and i'm curious is there any fitness
challenges or like diets that you regret
publicly attempting on your channel yes
and no because i've tried to as cliche
as it says live with no regrets because
i think the only reason i'm here and
have any knowledge or anything is that i
screwed up
so much like in the last 10 years it's
if i just wrote all my failures i was
like and that's the only reason i'm
where i am today and you know i have a
lot of bigger goals and definitely you
know where i want to go but i think the
friends family boyfriend career just my
passions i'm only here because i screwed
up a lot so i try not to have regrets
but that being said i think if i'd gone
back after the tom brady video i would
be like hey kelty i know the diet ones
are great but like what you because my
rationale back then was like you're
given this opportunity take it and run
and i was like you're giving this
opportunity take a run invent make the
video you want and then but that's you
know easier said than done it was just
me on my own like i was living in a city
by myself i had no one doing what i was
doing i was trying to figure it out so i
tried not to look back at regrets
because i'm here talking to you today
and so i'm very thankful for that but
definitely i think i would have
right then started making the videos i
always wanted to make and not just
appeal to the algorithm
yeah i feel you on that
um and let's talk about your thumbnails
for a second because i mean obviously
you have an amazing body and you should
rock it so no judgment um but i'm
curious if you feel like your videos
would perform as well as they do if you
didn't have like a lot of before and
after ab shots on your thumbnails this
something i'm even trying to figure out
is like um and luckily i just hired a
videographer and i'm hoping this
actually like solves this is like it's
so hard to make a thumbnail on i just
have my little like g7x and like just
try and take an intriguing thumbnail and
the reality is in the fitness health
community the best thing is like a
before and after because it is a story
your thumbnail should tell a story it
should be intriguing it and so
and everyone's clickbaiting at the end
of the day so you're against people
click baiting really bad things and so
i've always kind of tried
sometimes i do a challenge and sorry if
i'm going to jump one way but it'll end
up for the same i'll do a challenge and
not show my results before and after and
people in the comments are like well
why'd you even do this you're not
showing the results i'm like well it was
more entertaining educational and then i
show it and people like are you just
clickbaiting and then so i've tried to
find
the balance with it and i think i really
that's something i want to work on it's
like really intriguing thumbnails that
don't just involve their body and before
and afters but then at the same time a
lot of those videos what i try to also
do is show
when i was first starting youtube i
remember seeing all these body
transformations i'm not taking away from
anyone who's had beautiful body
transformation and so proud of himself
but i saw a lot that were faking it a
lot better photoshop a lot that were
posed differently and so sometimes i'll
purposely do that and then show myself
doing i know the one i had i think it
was
for a cycle like a 30 days spin class
and it showed how if i post differently
i have a thigh gap and so i've had that
in the thumbnail and then i did have my
journey you know i showed how my legs
changed but then i also showed a lot of
times people are
just
you know posing differently for these
thumbnails and i i see the irony that
i'm just posting different thumbnails
and i'm still feeding into the same
system but i also think you have to have
that
i'm just trying to have it more common
knowledge and i think actually tick-tock
has been good about that like just
calling people out and now people are
savvy enough that they're seeing like oh
that's that's
like someone is photoshopping themselves
someone is posed differently and so now
i'm kind of like okay you guys know that
so we can move past those trendy
thumbnails before and after and let's go
and then sometimes i do have
a body transformation i know you know i
got really back into athletic training
after and so i did have muscle so i was
like hey i'm gonna show that there it is
a journey and uh so it's it's a balance
and i'm trying to figure it out but i
hope that
in the murkiness of the bad sides of
youtube if my thumbnail can be more
intriguing at least i know
and not to put myself on a high horse
it's promoting something healthy if
someone is in a spiral because
we both know the algorithm feeds off
very negatively social dilemma showed
that that like eating disorder algorithm
you just start with the dye and then
before you know you've done that and so
i've always kind of liked
thinking that sometimes someone is on
that downward spiral and then they hit
my video and so there's sometimes i
think i'll always play into that just a
little occasionally not every video but
just knowing hey you know what someone
the algorithm has started you with
weight loss and dieting and suddenly
you're down in this really dark place
and my thumbnail somehow is in there but
then you're brought right back up to
love yourself love movie your body enjoy
food
yeah 100 and i totally get you i mean
the the youtube world is all about click
bait like just
just you got to just understand that
folks um and so i don't think there's
anything wrong with having um uh you
know an intriguing thumbnail or an
enticing um title but like you said as
long as the content itself is actually
helpful and supportive and it's funny
because i was just i just did a video i
don't know if you saw blair walnut's um
recent video about how she lost 20
pounds or something and or whatever it
was 20 pounds in a couple months or
whatever
well in that video she talked about why
she will manipulate her thumbnails to
like change her body size and things
like that and her rationale was the same
was like i'm hoping that someone will
click on my video and they'll be brought
to a good message
and i was like yes that's fair but the
message has to be good and so
in that case not so much but i agree
like you know there is that balance
there and sometimes people are searching
for for example like detox or cleanse
and if they click on my video that says
detox or cleanse hopefully they'll get
like a tutorial on the fact that you
just need to like take a sh and you'll
be cleansed you know so they'll be
served that that that truth bomb right
there so i i totally get that and it's
funny like i remember
one of your videos specifically
that it just came up in my feed and i'll
be honest i don't watch a lot of youtube
other than for work because it just it's
like triggering for me um but i
remember there was like one video that
was like i'm gaining weight or something
and in the image you're crying and i was
like i never click so fast i have to be
totally honest i clicked so [ __ ] fast
i don't even know why i care like that's
that's me it's like it tells me
something about like deep-seated um kind
of interest in in weight gain and weight
loss that like it's very hard to escape
that's diet culture for you that that's
even something that i talk about but
it's there
and i remember clicking on it and it was
actually quite happy video i mean there
was like some emotional parts in it too
but it was really about like
you trying to gain some weight to feel
like your best self and so like you said
like you know someone's someone's gonna
click on that being like oh my god she's
gaining weight like oh what you gonna do
and here you are being like yeah i'm
actually like purposefully trying to
feel my best and that includes weight
gain and that's okay that's a good thing
and i love that i never want someone to
click on a video and leave in like they
got cheated but i feel like they're like
oh that was even more than i expected so
that video yeah just came i done a
challenge right before and i just lost
weight and it was not like anything too
scary i was like i prefer myself i'm
just more athletic like five pounds
heavier um and then in that video i just
opened up i'm in a long-distance
relationship and we hadn't seen each
other for a year and i was like you know
i'm going through a lot of like mental
health things and like it was just
opening up and so that's why i was like
i was crying i was gaining weight but
it's not and then i just tried to
normalize because i think yeah someone
clicking on that is just very triggered
by like oh my god gaining weight is the
end of the world i just want to show
like it's not always a bad thing and
like you don't have to demonize it you
can be kind of subjective to it and so
exactly i think that's
the forever battle in youtube
100
i
totally agree
um and so i'm curious like i've watched
a lot of your videos and like i said
before i think that you seem to have a
very strong relationship with food and
it sounds like you know based on your
history that you do um do you ever worry
that you may like ostracize a subsect of
your audience or unintentionally like
water down some of these food freedom
messages while appealing to people who
are still like drawn in by that
aesthetic or fat loss promise
yeah and that's where
it is tricky and i'm forever navigating
that the unfortunate thing is and that's
where
i think we're starting to change and
this is why we're just trying to change
with my audience is
weight loss is the most clickbaity thing
that's why a lot of females get into
fitness that's why a lot of girls start
working out and you know i'm not going
to even demonize it because if that just
gets you to the gym and then you're
suddenly like oh that dumbbell is kind
of fun like let's try this and before
you know someone's doing crossfit and
like that sounds scary and if someone
watching this is like oh that'd never be
made like it's not a bad thing but i
think i am always worried that yes i'm
just
always navigating weight loss and people
are caring for weight loss i'm not
talking about weight loss but
i i just think that's just kind of my
mission is i think your body is just
this beautiful vessel that allows you to
do more like for me i've always just the
best envision is like i want to be
really athletic so when i go on a boat i
can jump off and dive into the water and
when i go to a music festival i can
dance till three a.m and like as much as
like overcoming challenges is really
good for confidence like that is why i
move i love it and i totally i am i'm
totally on board i always say i i
believe in body autonomy and so i don't
think that there's any value in shaming
people for wanting to lose weight even
if it's for aesthetic purposes like i
don't care
what's your why
um i just want people to believe that
and to know
that if they don't want to lose weight
they don't have to if they don't want to
get a six-pack they don't have to and
they can do what feels best for them and
you know that's really what diet culture
is trying to teach us and i want people
to know that they have choice they have
autonomy that they that they can do
what's actually best for them and not
just what another instagramer is telling
them that they have to do
um so yeah i'm all for the breadth of
that that message and making sure that
ultimately you're doing what kind of
feels good to you and also just like
having fun as well so i love that you're
promoting that
um okay i've got one more big question
but a fun one before that that i'm just
gonna slip in here because i figure like
we're talking about so much about um you
know letting our personality shine and
being our true self and and showing our
soul
real talk what's your favorite cocktail
actually not just cocktail like any
drink i need to just leave it open for
you go on about that i know you could
but like you can only pick one my
favorite drink is a good extra nejo
tequila just even just on the rocks but
here's the trick you get a really good
tequila or mezcal you chase it with
orange and cinnamon on it and so like
get a really it well like lime's good
but this like oh that would be like my
go-to so i've never
heard of that before but it's been a
while since i've been to like a cool bar
so um
but i will keep that in mind for the
next time i'm taking shots all right so
final question what are you most fed up
with in the health and fitness industry
i think just the black and white of it
is that like
keto is good
vegan's bad vice versa it's like
everyone's kind of it's like even i see
it a lot on youtube it's like the eating
disorder recovery community versus the
bodybuilding community and yet their
goals are going to be completely
different how they like one has to start
eating more butter and the one you know
they have very aesthetic goals and it's
about discipline and you know very rigid
and
i think it's just attacking the other
when people have completely different
goals completely different bodies some
girls don't want to wait that they've
tried it and they're like you know what
i'm more of a flowy person i want to do
yoga and dance and that's fine on the
flip side i was like have you ever tried
weightlifting that might be really
confident building and you know someone
wants to go to spin class is that the
most optimal way to glory grow your
glutes no but it's really fun it feels
like a nightclub on your internet and i
think it's just that not attacking each
other so much and just being so against
each other it's more supporting that at
the end of the day all fitness and
health is is just like
allowing you to live a longer better
life and enjoying your journey and
whatever as long as everyone's in that
direction they're bettering themselves
whether it be increasing their pr having
a healthier relationship with food
losing a little bit of weight even just
the weight loss weight gain community
they're the same and they're different
and we're on the same journey but they
can be in completely different bodies
and completely different methods and i
think we
i've always tried to promote on my
channel and i really hope and i see you
do this is that it's just more of like
you see someone doing something
completely different
than you but they're not harming anyone
and they're doing better for themselves
we're like you clap that even if it
doesn't resonate with you at all as long
as you see someone doing better by
themselves like listen to their story
and i think if we hear each other's
stories we would resonate a lot more
with each other and not just paint like
oh she's a weightlifter oh she's a yogi
oh she's i think i was like are you
happier are you living in your more
fulfilled life yes and i was like then
you're all on the same journey and i
hopefully the fitness community does
that except for some stuff that's like
really bad like detoxies and
and we could just all
throw that out the window agreed that we
don't even need to entertain us like
well maybe it's like no
no we're good yeah i totally agree well
thank you so much kelty i really
appreciate it i think we've all learned
so much and of course i'm going to leave
some links below in my description for
people to be able to find you so thank
you for joining me thank you so much fun
just having a little chit chat i really
appreciate it and thank you for
everything you do it's been so
refreshing i know even growing up on
youtube it was a lot of like well i'm
not a registered dietitian i could it's
so nice like you're enjoyable to watch
but you're there's finally like a
dietitian out there that like people can
actually turn to and no it's not just
someone who took one course like you
genuinely know what you're talking about
and you present it in a really fun way
so thank you for that thank you
uh and guys i hope you enjoyed this
video if you did be sure to give it the
thumbs up also leave me a comment below
on who you'd like to see me uh interview
next i'm very excited to continue this
series subscribe to the channel and i'll
see you next time on abby's kitchen bye
you